les comiques ont la vie dure sans doute
parce qu'ils nous sont farouchement
indispensable on ne cesse de débusquer
les inédits de desproges de reiser et de
coluche de ce dernier paraît aux
éditions du cherche midi
un recueil posthume de mots et
d'aphorismes et vous trouvez ça drôle
la réponse est oui sans aucun doute
coluche et drôle
roboratif sont très fait mouche il porte
les exemples à l'appel voler c'est quand
on trouve un objet avant qu'il soit
perdu
on parle souvent du boulevard des filles
du calvaire mais jamais du calvaire des
filles du boulevard
hier j'ai été mangé chez le pape
qu'est-ce qu'il est sympa mais alors sa
femme
coluche avait une affection particulière
pour l'artichaut qu'il juge est un
légume de pauvres il double de volume
quand on la fine quelques flèches
gentille à l'encontre de carlos de
chantal goya ou de francis lalanne
celui ci donne un concert dans une
petite ville et l'après-midi l'épicier
du cru vous êtes arrivé un type qui lui
dit je voudrais vous achetez tout votre
stock de tomates pourries ah je vois dit
l'autre ce soir vous allez au gala de
francis lalanne nous je suis francis
lalanne